welcome to this episode of clicks to
deploy a series where we show you how
easy it is to deploy solutions from the
google cloud marketplace
in this episode we'll be reviewing how
to set up fortigate next generation
firewall virtual appliance fortigate vm
via the cloud marketplace
in case you're unfamiliar fortigate vm
delivers the same firewall and secure
sc1 capabilities for organizations of
all sizes
similar to those offered by fortinet's
industry-leading solutions it enables
broad content and network protection
plus it automates management for
consistent enforcement and visibility
across your hybrid cloud infrastructure
let's start by searching for fordigate
in the cloud marketplace we'll choose
the solution fortigate next generation
firewall p-a-y-g
to deploy fortigate we need to ensure
that the compute engine
cloud deployment and cloud runtime apis
have been enabled before we choose our
specs make sure to review the usage fee
for choosing the solution
which shows you infrastructure fees for
choosing the solution based on vm
instance and ssd
let's choose our specs
we'll start with deployment name for
this tutorial i'll choose fortigate101
then zone let's choose us central one
next machine family we will choose
series e2 and e2 medium with two vcpus
which provides day-to-day computing at a
lower cost
then boot disk we'll choose ssd
persistent disk and a boot disk size of
10 gigabytes
for log disk we'll enable log disk and
use the default
for fortigate we'll choose the most
recent image version of 7.0.2
finally firewall depending on your needs
you can choose what type of connection
you will allow and for what ip address
ranges if any for this tutorial we will
leave all selected
click the deploy button to launch the
solution as you can see our fortigate
firewall has been deployed
let's log into the admin panel and
change the temporary password
you'll find the admin user and temporary
password right on the deployment manager
[Music]
there you have it fortigate next
generation firewall deployed with a
click of a button
if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe and hit the like button below
we encourage you to check out the google
cloud marketplace and deploy this
solution on your own thanks for watching
[Music]
you